je reçois maintenant philip morris
[Musique]
bonjour bonsoir bonsoir
physiquement il bonsoir pour soins donc
été condamné à mort en 1991 pour le
meurtre d'un policier
grâcié par françois mitterrand en 1981
votre peine a été commuée en prison à
perpétuité vous êtes passé 23 ans
derrière les barreaux la moitié de votre
vie est là en prison vous devenez un
grand spécialiste de l'histoire
médiévale ou fait une thèse sur la
famille en gévaudan au xvème siècle et
avec mention il publie un livre pour
raconter votre histoire qui était
extraordinaire ça s'appelle de la haine
à la vie c'est aux éditions du cherche
midi voilà alors j'imagine que quand
vous êtes sorti de prison il ya un an
vous aviez aucune envie d'écrire un
livre sur ce sujet vous l'avez fait pour
soutenir la les abolitionnistes parce
que c'est un bel exemple
contre la peine de mort en tous les cas
vous faites donc le faisais je ne
voulais pas spécialement écrire de
livres bon on a fini par me solliciter
par et
ce n'est pas mon histoire que j'ai écrit
même si même si c'est une partie de mon
existence c'est plutôt un une expérience
dont j'ai voulu faire part dans la
mesure où le problème qui m'intéresse le
plus c'est celui des jeunes qui
aujourd'hui dans les banlieues sont les
jeunes qui sont exposés à toutes sortes
de problèmes et qu'ils peuvent faire de
mauvais choix de vins et des choix qui
vont les mener à la prison et qui vont
parfois les confronter à une escalade
escalade à laquelle chez je me suis
livrée moi même alors pour éviter les
reproches qui pourrait vous êtes fait
parce que c'est vrai qu'avec soliva
marché c'est évident et vous allez en
vendre beaucoup vous à gagner de
l'argent j'ai décidé d'en donner une
grosse part âgées aux familles des
victimes en fait il n'y aura pas
d'argent pour moi quasiment pas du moins
l'argent va aller aux partis s'ils
viennent donc aux victimes aux familles
des victimes
et puis au fisc puisque ce qui semble un
peu aberrant quelques noms mais n'ayant
pas de revenu je trouve aberrant de
devoir payer de l'argent au fisc alors
qu'il serait mieux que la totalité aille
aux familles de victimes alors d'un côté
vous parlais pas beaucoup quand même du
policier que vous avez tué cci pourquoi
je ne souhaitais pas chercher quelque
chose qui soit sensationnel je ne
voulais pas bon il ya cela et puis
en
fait il est vrai que je n'avait sans
doute pas envie d'extraire de moi
une partie enfin cette partie là et vous
vous y pensez souvent c'était bidon de
toute façon quand quand on a une vie
comme la mienne quand on s'est fourvoyé
comme moi il est bien évident que les
choses sont là et maintenant au delà de
cela il est bien évident que mon passé
est irréparable et mon passé je le porte
clés en moi il ne s'éteindra pas de
passé et inexpiable c'est à dire vous
par exemple vous vous excusez pas auprès
des familles de la victime parce que
vous pensez que le pardon serait
ridicule dans une situation pareille de
toute façon je pense que
je pense que parfois il serait insultant
de demander à quelqu'un de me décharger
de ce qu'il ya en moi ouais ce qu'il est
en moi je dois le jeu doit le garder on
parlait pas non plus de l' avocate
stagiaire qui vous avez fait passer une
arme en prison à un moment avant vouliez
vous évadez vous êtes fait attraper vous
avez vous évader sa carrière a été
brisée vous en parlez pas non plus alors
pour une bonne raison c'est quelqu'un
j'en parle très peu dans le livre le
moins possible c'est quelqu'un qui a
aujourd'hui refait sa vie et qui ne
souhaitent pas du tout que l'on parle
d'accord et donc voilà c'est le plus
important dans ce cas là le billet se
bat non non biens sociaux n'est pas ce
qu'elle veut c'est quelqu'un qui ne
souhaitent pas du tout que l'on parle
d'elle alors on peut dire quelque chose
votre père était policier
en fait souvent dans les articles dans
la presse on l'a dit tiens le fils d'un
policier etc en fait votre père a quitté
le foyer familial à ces jeunes donc ça
n'a pas grand chose à voir le fait non
mes parents ont divorcé j'avais 6 ans il
n'y a jamais eu de problème d'ailleurs
entre mon père et un et moi même annoncé
le
ça n'a rien à voir ces terrains alors
vous êtes en contact avec la marginalité
assez tout parce que votre frère est
emprisonné pour une histoire de trafic
de voitures vous lui rendez visite en
secret et là vous commencez à sentir ce
goût un petit peu d'illégalité de la
marginalité au départ pour aider votre
frère tout simplement parce qu'il
voulait s'évader donc voulu aller le
voir et là vous vous mettez le doigt
dans l'engrenage d'une certaine façon
alors moi j'ai trouvé totalement anormal
que mon frère soit soit mis en prison
j'aimais mon frère en outre il avait été
interpellé dans une affaire dans
laquelle se trouvait
un membre du sac service d'action
civique est cette personne elle n'a
jamais été mise en prison je veux pas
dire ça n'aurait servi à rien que cette
personne soit mise en prison mais en
tout cas mon frère y était j'avais une
injustice qui vous est de toute façon
déjà révoltés bon ça c'est un miroir mon
frère voulait s'évader à partir de là je
trouvais normal de l'aider à s'évader
dès lors il est vrai qu'on est pas son
frère à s'évader de prison en
allons travailler comme aide comptable
et donc j'ai mis le pied dans
l'engrenage est alors j'ai rencontré des
personnes j'ai découvert aussi
une forme de belvis à savoir que en
banlieue
l'argent les produits de luxe n'existe
pas tellement et là dans cette ville a
bien sûr je découvrais des boutiques
comme fauchon découvrait des hôtels
agréable je découvrais les belles
voitures et il est vrai que tout en
commençant à aider mon frère je
découvrais une autre vie dans laquelle
il était agréable de serre alors en 77
vous finissez par être incarcéré enfin à
rodez d'abord quelques mois rodez et
ensuite à la prison de la santé il a
effectivement ça a été le basculement
vous êtes passé à tabac quand vous
arrivez à la santé il ouvre les fenêtres
il voulait ce parterre vous êtes bleus
de froid légende le sexe partout bleus
de froid et une photo de votre fiancée
quand vous revenez il ya quelqu'un qui a
marché volontairement sur la photo est
là dans celle que vous voyez des gens en
uniforme qui ne respectent pas la loi
c'est à dire que jusqu'à présent vous
aviez quand même le sentiment que la
société devait se faire respecter et que
les gens qui la faisait respecter
souvent uniforme et vous basculez quand
vous avez une vingtaine d'années et que
des gens comme ça des gens en uniforme
vous route coup on casse quelque chose
d'autre on place on casse quelque chose
qui se trouve dans votre tête et j'ai
écrit dans le livre que ce jour là il
avait tué je sais plus si j'ai dit
l'enfant ou le gosse
et c'est vrai qu'à partir de ce moment
là beaucoup de choses basculent la seule
chose qui me retenait encore c'était
l'amour j'avais ma fiancée que j'aimais
qui m'aimait encore et je me suis
accroché à cela avec beaucoup de force
la force du désespoir fin août
malheureusement quand on doit passer
quatre ans en prison très souvent
l'amour s'émousse et quand l'amour
disparaît pour moi en tout cas il n'y
avait plus rien plus rien et il y avait
que la volonté de ne plus rester en
prison voilà volonté d'en sortir mais
sortir par tous les moyens alors charb
et riss et je pensais ça si vous avez
fait un film avec boralex a fait
l'addition de nyama où effectivement
c'est un rapport comme ça entre le le
prisonnier le matin et le matin et c'est
enfin c'est malheureusement assez
souvent le le sort de beaucoup de
détenus qui débarque pour peu qu'ils
soient un petit peu insolent
ça arrive souvent il faut dire aussi que
le travail des matons et ajuste un
terrible justement ce que je vais dire
ces dernières il faut respecter aussi
beaucoup ce travail fasoli me disais en
68 les vrais prolétaires c'est pas les
étudiants évidemment parce que c'était
comme vous le disiez tout à l'heure
d'ailleurs c'est vrai que les vrais
prenez les étudiants qui manifestaient
c'étaient les petits bourgeois c'est la
majorité silencieuse états unis disaient
les vrais prolétaires c'est les crs bien
sûr et c'est vrai que
ils sont enfermés aussi les matons le
gardien de prison qui fait son métier
oui il n'y a rien à lui reprocher quand
il fait son métier le problème c'est
quand il commet des actes qui n'ont rien
et narre avec son travail et est
malheureusement tel que le système
existe il n'ya pas voir est bastonné un
homme dans une dans une cellule ce n'est
pas normal
lui infliger d'autres brimades vous
citiez tout à l'heure l'exemple de la
photo piétiner volontairement mais il y
en a plein comme ça de et tout cela ce
n'est pas normal et là il devrait y
avoir sanction or le système couvre et
un détenu qui est roué de coups et qui
portent plainte de travers c'est ça il
porte plainte et alors la procédure a
été abandonnée car les témoins certifié
qu'il ne s'était rien passé l'était
moins c'était ce qui allait la faire et
de coûts et ses cascades cas les bains
lorsque
il y à des gardiens qui sont des adeptes
de la violence celui qui n'en est pas
adeptes il est quand même obligé de
faire semblant parce que sinon il n'est
pas solidaire du corps et il s'exclut
lui même mais le problème c'est que
l'institution permet que cela se passait
donc il faut réformer l'institution
il faut réformer il faut donner fixé un
but à la prison il faut dire aux
gardiens comment ils doivent travailler
il faut leur a donné une déontologie et
à partir de là les choses serait très
difficile n'était pas comme ça avec vous
parce que vous aviez but est un flic
parce que c'est quand même on se fait au
delà
la rage qu'il y a eu à mon encontre de
la perdre un gardien ne vient pas de là
elle vient d'une tentative d'évasion que
que j'ai tenté alors que j'étais
condamné à mort voilà je l'attendais
d'être exécutée j'ai tenté un malade et
cela raté et cela échoue et du moins et
j'ai blessé un gardien en tentant de
partir bon vent voulons continuer
l'histoire d'entraînement vous subissez
ces vexations ces brimades vous est
rongé par la haine parce que c'est vrai
que la haine dans ces moments là c'est
un moyen de survie c'est le seul moteur
qui vous restent ceux l'énergie kivu est
c'est la haine alors ça fait vivre et ça
détruit ça ronge de l'intérieur en même
temps la haine c'est quand on a une
véritable reine en soit ce qu'il ya de
terrible c'est que c'est très douloureux
la haine fait physiquement mal la haine
la haine je la compare un peu à un
ulcère un ulcère très très virulent et
donc et d'un autre côté c'est vrai
qu'elle permet aussi de vivre elle
permet de supporter le le
le mur que l'on vous oppose les
vexations que l'on vous inflige un jour
je me suis rendu compte que 7 n était d
très destructrice pour moi est très
dangereuse parce que lorsque vous vous
haïssez comme ça le jour où en face de
vous vous avez quelqu'un qui vous
inflige une brimade vous risquez de ne
pas pouvoir vous contrôlez et donc vous
devenez dangereux pour les autres en
plus de vous détruire et à partir de ce
moment-là il y à un moment où moi je me
suis dit bon il faut arriver à désarmer
cette n1 avant ça justement avant ça il
ya cette attente de la mort parce que
c'est vrai vous êtes dans le couloir de
la mort comme on dit en parlant des et
qu'on avait un mort américains c'est à
dire que toute heure qui passe vous
rapproche inexorablement de la mort mais
on fait tout ce qu'on peut évidemment
pour le garder en vie donc ça devient
absurde c'est à dire que par exemple
quand vous cessez de vous alimentez on
vous alimente de force et il ya un
dialogue surréaliste avec un médecin de
fresnes qui dit je dois vous maintenir
en vie pour qu'on puisse vous exécutez
donc c'est devient kafkaïen encore une
fois - et le condamner à mort n'a pas le
droit de se suicider ouais enfin
il n'a pas le droit d'être tué non plus
autrement à dire que la suite de ma
tentative d'évasion bien sûr le
personnel m'en voulait énormément et
et certains avaient envie de
en fait j'ai même un peu peut-être
failli être tué quand j'ai échoué mais
mais les ordre était donné pour ne
surtout pas me tuer
il fallait que je dis c'est que je veux
tu en voilà donc là on est en 80 donc
giscard d'estaing hésite les élections
arrivent il sait pas très bien ce qu'il
faut faire c'est vrai qu'à l'époque faut
dire c'est encore le cas maintenant mais
la majorité de la population française
était favorable à la peine de main et
mitterrand a pris une décision très très
courageuse puisque c'était pas
démagogique pour le coup donc lui voue
grassi
et et vous dites choses extraordinaires
but avant d'être graciés je considérais
que j'avais des droits face à des gens
qui allaient me couper en morceaux
d'avion vous êtes graciée vous avez plus
de droits à la violence et c'est
peut-être là effectivement vous
commencez à échapper à la haine non à
partir du moment où on me laisser vivre
il était bien évident que je ne pouvais
plus me permettre
tous que ce serait des affaires en tous
les cas oui dans la rue de penne donc
est commuée en prison à perpétuité
d'abord vaincu hs ensuite une détention
normale et là vous parvenez à canaliser
votre haine votre énergie votre vie
pour l'histoire en fait vous lancer dans
l'histoire alors pour les gardiens c'est
très bien parce qu'un détenu qui
travaillent 200 détenus qui se gardent
tout seul donc ça c'est pour eux c'est
évidemment beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
facile et vous vous évadez vous finissez
pouvoir comprendre que la meilleure
façon de vous évader c'est pas par la
fenêtre c'est dans les livres mais
disons que à partir du moment où j'ai je
me suis rendu compte donc cet homme
devait être éteintes
bon j'avais quand même déjà fait une
dizaine d'années
j'avais atteint déjà un niveau d'étude
j'étais à peu près au niveau de la
maîtrise et je me suis rendu compte que
ma vie que j'aurais souhaité
voire être différente je me suis rendu
compte que je pouvais aussi la
réorienter et que j'en avais les moyens
donc donc à partir de là j'ai cessé de
calculer la hauteur des murs pour
essayer de l'escaladé et je me suis
résigné à purger ma peine jusqu'au bout
avec toutefois une difficulté c'est
qu'une peine perpétuelle on en connaît
jamais le bout je suis aujourd'hui libre
donc au bout de 23 ans de prison mais je
pourrais encore être à l'intérieur pour
une période de 10 ans oui des revenants
liberté conditionnelle dans une certaine
qu'on disait en liberté conditionnelle
pendant dix ans mais alors la bon vous
travaillez et c'est à dire 16 heures par
jour vous étudiez des tas de bouquins
500 livres lorsque pas drôle je sais pas
si c'est drôle d'en face qui sait que le
règlement vous interdit d'avoir plus de
dix livres dans votre cellule alors
voulu trafic des vivres il colle dès que
ces gens semblent plusieurs que sèche
pour en faire un seul donc la boum tout
ça pour avoir le plus de livres possible
d'entrer parce que les études qui
faisait sa demande d'aidé des tas de
bouquins et puis vous commencez à être
mieux considérer mieux traités à ce
moment là aussi par le personnel
pénitentiaire
d'une certaine façon vous êtes un peu
élargie disons
bien que jusqu'à la fin il ya une chose
que vous racontez c'est qu'à la fin donc
au dernier moment le dernier jour ils
vous font encore attendre une heure par
une espèce de brimades comme ça vous
devez sortir quoi en fait j'avais
demandé à quelle heure je sortais
puisque je travaillais dehors le jour je
travaillais j'avais donc demander à
quelle heure je sortais pour pouvoir me
rendre à mon travail et une collègue de
bureau est venu me chercher à l'heure
dite et le fait elle leur dit et bien
on m'a fait savoir au dernier moment que
ça serait pas cette heure-là on a
enfermé dans une cellule alors que la
levée d'écrou était fait que tout est
fait je pouvais sortir mais on m'a
maintenu là et on m'a bien fait
comprendre que c'était un acte
volontaire votre livre a beaucoup de
succès il est très apprécié on en parle
beaucoup et pourtant vous avez pas vous
dit très très clairement vocation à
devenir le condamner à mort des médias
quoi c'est à dire voulait bien être
utile pour faire passer un certain
nombre de messages mais pas non plus
faire que ça c'est à dire que là dans
quinze jours vous allez retourner à
l'anonymat de vos recherches je suis je
suis historien je prépare une bio sur
guillaume le conquérant et en fait c'est
quand même c'est quand même votre
boisson c'est mon travail mais vous êtes
devenu un symbole est aujourd'hui le
symbole des gens qui disent voyait la
peine de mort a été abolie c'est bien
regarder on peut s'amender on peut on
peut on peut s'en sortir vraiment besoin
d'être l'exemple est vraiment le pire ce
serait que vous rechute y est déjà moi
je ne me sens pas vraiment un symbole
mais je peux comprendre je comprends que
pour d'autres je sois un cas un cas quoi
mais au-delà de ça ça ne me gêne pas
dans la mesure où ma vie mes choix de
vie sont même très anciens si vous
voulez à l'intérieur
donc en prison j'avais déjà fait j'ai
fait mes choix depuis plusieurs années
il n'y a pas de problème est ce que vous
avez envie richard de poser une question
à philippe
sella j'aimerais bien lui parler oui
mais je savais qu est ce une question
voilà bien un philip morris merci de ce
témoignage on va vous laisser partir
merci d'être venu témoigner richard si
vous voulez discuter oui allez-y
ensemble d'accords si vous êtes d'accord
vous avez parlé tous les deux dans les
loges au revoir merci allait enfin voilà
ça s'appelle de la haine à la vie philip
morris et c'est aux éditions du cherche
midi voilà
les corrections de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux